sometimes I'll start a sentence and I
don't even know where it's going I just
hope I find it along the way
like an improv conversation
an improvisation you need to go back
there and you need to Pretty Woman their
asses we should start our own Mall yeah
wait wait actually that's a really good
idea Kelly what did I say I talk a lot
so I've learned to just tune myself out
you're Ali Larder I'm Beyonce I Am
Beyonce always I am running away from my
responsibilities
arm feels good
would I rather be feared or loved
um easy both
I want people to be afraid of how much
they love me
and I think I proved that today at the
dojo
what is the most inspiring thing I ever
said to you
don't be an idiot changed my life
whenever I'm about to do something I
think would an idiot do that and if they
would I do not do that thing
I'm not superstitious but I'm I am a
little stitches
all right ready come on guys Hurley worm
gets the worm
another worm like are they friends daily
you will not die
we found ourselves on the less prepared
side of things when Stanley had his
when his heart went berserk
and I knew exactly what to do but in a
much more real sense I had no idea what
to do
finals go sit at my desk and be quiet
sorry I annoyed you with my friendship
I wish I could menstruate
if I could menstruate I wouldn't have to
deal with idiotic calendars anymore I'd
just be able to count down from my
previous cycle
plus I'd be more in tune with the moon
and the tides
I live by one rule
no office romances no way very messy
inappropriate
no
but
I live by another rule
just do it
Nike worst thing about prison was that
was the Dementors they were flying all
over the place and they were scary and
then they come down and they suck the
soul out of your body and at height Jim
is my enemy but it turns out that Jim is
also His Own Worst Enemy and the enemy
of my enemy is my friend so Jim is
actually my friend
but because he is his Own Worst Enemy
the enemy of my friend is my enemy so
actually Jim is my enemy
but what if we all get together and help
each other and hire a new guy and then
we all kill him but first we take out
like a hundred thousand dollar life
insurance policy I bet you guys like
that idea don't you
I think that's what they're doing to me
I can't prove it but I wanted to see
their faces when I said it
I learned nothing
I don't know what that was I just drove
my car into a lake you did what I drove
my car into a lake
finally I want to thank God
because God gave me this Dundee
and I feel God in this Chili's tonight
sort of an Oaky after birth
in the end the greatest snowball isn't a
snowball at all
it's fear
Merry Christmas
an early bird and I'm a night owl so I'm
wise and I have worms
wow you all took a life here today
you did
the life of the party
that is a great idea ultimatums are key
basically nobody does anything for me
anymore unless I threaten to kill myself
Jan is about to have a baby with a sperm
donor and Michael is preparing for the
birth of a watermelon with Dwight now
this baby will be related to Michael
through
delusion I had created a website with
this many problems I'd kill myself do
you have a question Kelly yeah I have a
lot of questions number one how dare you
what I really want honestly Michael is
for you to know it so that you can
communicate
clients to whomever oh okay what
it's whoever not whomever not whomever
no whomever is never actually right well
sometimes it's right Michael is right
it's a made-up word used to trick
students no actually whomever is the
formal version of the word obviously
it's a real word but I don't know when
to use it correctly I'm not a native
speaker I know what's right but I'm not
gonna say because you're all jerks who
didn't come see my band last night do
you really know which one is correct I
don't know it's whom when it's the
object of the sentencing who when is the
subject that sounds right well it sounds
right but is it how did Ryan use it as
an object as an object Chinese me as an
object is he right about that how did he
use it again it was Ryan wanted Michael
the subject to explain the computer
system the object guilt to whomever
meaning us the indirect object which is
the the correct usage of the word no one
uh asks you anything ever so whomever's
name is Toby why don't you take a letter
opener and stick it in your skull wait
this is
lunch and I'm
do I need to be liked absolutely not I
like to be liked I enjoy being liked
I have to be liked
but it's not like this
impulsive need to be liked like my need
to be praised saying that we're the tour
manager for Justin Bieber and we're
giving away free tickets we give them a
number to call for the tickets and it's
his number who is Justice beaver
it's a crime fighting beaver
why are you the way that you are
honestly every time I try to do
something fun or exciting you make it
not that way
I hate
so much about the things that you choose
to be
okay you know what Meredith
you lit your hair on fire today what
about tomorrow what is going to happen
when you come into work and you're dead
I stab her in the brain with a wooden
stick
depression
too many people on this Earth we need a
new plague
I declare
bankruptcy
I wanted you to know that you can't just
say the word bankruptcy and expect
anything to happen I didn't say it I
declared it I want you to think about
your future at this company I want you
to think about it long and hard that's
what she
you're Ali Larter I'm Beyonce I Am
Beyonce always
sounds like a good dentist oh yeah
yeah what's his name
crentist
your dentist's name is krentus
huh
sounds a lot like dentist
maybe that's why he became a dentist
we see your teeth
let me see him let me see him
oh
foreign
what can I do you can get up
right
get up
and you can hug it out